hi everyone I'm Alana which are alonso
and last week I went to movie world to
check out the launch of their new
attraction which is the evil within maze
movie world is an Australian theme park
probably one of Australia's most popular
theme parks we don't really have that
many though they basically just make
this Magus that takes I don't know maybe
5-10 minutes to get through and they
actually printed out textures from game
itself to put all over the walls and
everything so that it matches the game
and then they have actors in there that
jump out at you at certain points while
you're walking through the maze there's
just lots of jump-scares so I'm not
allowed to show you a lot of it because
then it would ruin the surprise but
people who are going to eb expo next
week there's a mini version of the maids
it's going to be set up at Sydney
Olympic Park I'll be there so I'll see
you guys around but this is my time with
the evil within maze
[ __ ] I'm already terrified there are a
bunch of dead people in him being fun so
the snap this is what I'm like exactly
when I play horror games I can't see
through here I can't see Jesus Lou to it
once is too much that's what she said oh
my god this is the end oh my god I am
physically sore from walking through
that and my stomach being tense the
entire time because I'm so terrified of
jump-scares like actually my stomach
muscles are sore so I guess it did its
job extremely well i did also get to
play a little bit of the evil within
itself on the ps4 and I mean it's a lot
like resident evil it's being made my
Shinji Mikami who is responsible for
Resident Evil so that makes sense and
it's basically you have no person
survival horror you did also make
vanquish which is one of my favorite
games but that's a whole other thing I
didn't get to play enough of the game to
really talk about it adequately but it
was creepy and I definitely noticed the
importance of valuing it your ammunition
because you can run out really fast and
just get screwed over I'm Ilana thank
you for watching and I'll see you guys
next time